I'm Jad Abumrad,
this is Radiolab and this is the third
and final part of our series in the know
about sex and consent.
We started a couple of weeks ago with
some excerpts from a podcast called the
heart, uh, produced by Caitlin pressed.
Uh, and then last week had a long, uh,
at times difficult conversation
with education consultant.
Hanta Startland heard a bit from uh,
some college age men in that episode. Uh,
today?
Yes, I do have my shoes. Yes. Have
you? Anyone was looking for shoes.
Get comfortable. We're going to
start with some college age women.
If you need to stretch, you can like
be like, hey, it's been too long.
Like we can do yoga. No,
because what we ended up doing a sort
of mid way through the process was
gathering together a whole bunch of
different groups of men and women,
college age men and women,
three different cities and just asking
them general questions about how they're
thinking about this stuff.
Are you excited? No. I ended
up interviewing the Manson.
I'll turn this part over to Becca Bressler
and she [inaudible] who were with the
women,
the average group that we talked
to was maybe a dozen women.
We tried to make it as diverse as possible
and then the first thing
that really struck us,
I think she might tell me if you agree,
is there was sort of a disconnect.
Like on the one hand it seemed like
affirmative consent for almost everyone we
talked to seemed like second nature. Yeah.
So a actually teach like a workshop
on consent for high schoolers.
Some of them have you even teaching
classes on it? Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
So you know like ca to, yeah.
So like a clear and concise yes.
At every step of sexual activity.
I think that's like amazing that we're
teaching kids that now and like I do feel
like it's my generation's problem to
change it and change the narrative about
it. So a lot of them were really committed
to actually changing the way consent
looks, the way that these sexual
experiences go and how they're navigated.
But then when we would, you know,
focus in on what they were actually
experiencing in their lives,
what we saw was much different.
It's my friend and I
ended up at a bar. Um,
and like the bartender was really cute
and we were like flirting and he like,
I don't want to give any identifying
information, but we were just like vibing.
And I like hooked up with him.
And then like immediately after I started
hooking up with him, I was like, oh,
this is not what I want. But like at
that point it's kind of like saying no,
it would be like much
more of an uncomfortable
situation than just like going
through with this and like understanding
that I already regretted kind,
I don't know,
didn't leave, but eventually I was
just like, okay, fine, like whatever.
Cause they would just be like, please,
like, come on please. Like, you know,
you're turned on a little bit like,
and I'd be like, fine, whatever.
Like let's find, let's fuck.
And he was going down on me and like
had asked me if I to have sex and I said
no.
And eventually like I just like kind of
wanted it to be like over with like the
entire interaction and I was just
uncomfortable and then I was like, okay,
like let's have sex just because I thought
that like that was the easier way to
like make him happy, make like get
done with it and then like it be over.
We just heard a lot of stories of people
having sex that they didn't want to
have. You know where maybe
affirmative was in effect.
They did say yes but it was either because
the guy wore them down or they were
way too concerned with how he was feeling
like it would make him
feel really, really bad.
I know that like if he would have known
that I felt that way he would have gone
through with it and like I just didn't
want to like hurt his feelings and be
like and make him feel like he like
took advantage of me or whatever.
When I knew that there would be no
possible way that he would know that I was
feeling that way.
Some women told us that they say yes
sometimes when they don't want to because
they're scared.
Part of the fear and saying a hard no is
that that hard no can then be violated
and that's like, that's
like a terrifying thought.
Like to say like a hard no,
like that's more traumatizing to me like
in my head almost than having like a
soft, no,
just sort of like slid past
having fear of future trauma.
Like say it again. It's like
having a fear of future trauma. Um,
I take that to mean if your aim is to
stay in control and you feel like you
might be out of control,
then the best way to still be in control
is to convince yourself that you are
cool with what's going on. Wow.
I walked away feeling like many of the
young women felt frustrated both with
their world but also
with themselves. Yeah.
Afterwards I would feel
like very disappointed in
myself because I would feel
like add compromise my own needs for other
people that they would walk away from
a situation and they would
have regretted how it went.
They maybe didn't actually want to do
it but didn't stick up for themselves.
And then I, and then you fight like a
battle with yourself cause it's like,
wait a minute. Like I'm like strong.
Like I know I can like
just stop it or like why?
But it's so hard at like in
that moment to find like,
I don't know like the, the words just
to say it, you know, cause then it,
it sometimes you're just like,
yeah it is just easier just to be like
let it like just like let them finish.
That's it.
Like it was clear for most of these women
that in the moment of these encounters
there were some conversation that
needed to happen that was not happening.
But then there actually was this one
young woman that we spoke to. Some people,
I think a lot of people talk about consent
as if it's like awkward and weird and
like, like she just said,
con consent has really become popularized
and is really well advocated for by
the BDSM community.
[inaudible]
BDSM is an abbreviation, so
it, it breathes gates, bondage,
discipline or domination,
sadism and masochism because
you constantly have to
make sure that somebody is
okay and be like this, this
rope to tight. She told us,
I mean the BDSM community has this
figured out and then she started talking
about her own experience. So we've started
like, hmm, uh, what does that mean?
That the BDSM community
has figured that out?
Whoa. Hello? You got
a buzz there? Oh yeah.
It's like the B 52 bomber buzz.
Oh, that
sounds better. All right. Okay. Hi.
Hey. Good it we did it. We did it.
Did you feel like,
I always feel like after these technical
snafoos there's like a bonding that
happens. I feel bonded to you guys.
Well actually it's statistically true
thing that people suffering together feel
bonded to one another. Well, there you go.
[inaudible]
who are you by the way? What
do you do? My name is Julie.
I am an associate professor of sociology
at Gallaudet University and I've been
studying the BDSM
community since about 2012
we called up Julie
because she is one of the,
I think it's safe to say
leading academics, uh,
when it comes to the BDSM community
and all of its subculture.
She has written papers,
she has done surveys and she
has done it from the inside.
A lot of kickstarters like me pretty
much felt like we were sort of born this
way and it's really common to talk to
a lot of Kinky people who will tell you
the same thing.
Like I was five and fantasizing
about tying up people's Genitalia and
it's deep stuff, right? I
didn't know what genitals were.
Anyhow, one of the things
that we heard from Julie,
and we subsequently heard this also from
a lot of academics that we talked to
after her,
is it the whole consent conversation
in many ways grew out of BDSM a lot.
A lot of people will trace
like the history of BDSM
in the United States to the
leatherman community. [inaudible]
haven't you heard? Oh,
this is a World War II era. By the way.
These gay men would hang
out in biker clubs at bars.
They would socialize.
They were a really tight knit
brotherhood over the decades.
The brother who grew into this much bigger
community and then it really exploded
in the 80s but there's a problem at the
time no one had ever really formally
distinguished between BDSM,
a practice between willing
participants and violence.
Video Sam I think had to make the case
to the vanilla community to the non
[inaudible] community that they were not
insane but people were not getting off
on hurting people. That it was about
roles and role playing and power.
This is Joe for Shell.
He's an associate professor of women's
gender and sexuality studies at Yale
Central.
The slogan to convince non people that
what they were doing was not violence or
crime.
The full slogan they came up with
and this is in the 80s was safe,
sane and consensual and it
really stuck to this day.
You can find it on
t-shirts. You can at any of,
at any BDSM community event or play party,
ah, parties that are organized
at, uh, formal spaces,
they're called dungeons. Right?
So getting back to Julia,
we asked her, uh, okay,
if it is true as that one woman
said that the BDSM community,
if it is true that they have figured
something out about how to do it better,
well what is it? And uh, she told us
a couple of things. First drinking
my way of thinking
that's incredibly risky,
very frowned upon in the BDSM world
and the video sem scene. In my mind,
that's what we'd call edge play,
which is like kind of the things
that people do where you're like, ah,
that seems like a bad idea. Negotiating
sex when both people are really,
really drunk with somebody that you've
never met before qualifies as really,
really risky.
And speaking of that negotiation.
Another thing that was an interesting
contrast between the quote vanilla world
and BDSM is that when two
people are negotiating,
they're trying to figure out
if are going to get down. Uh,
in BDSM that conversation is
formalized and it's often public
because generally speaking, most of
what's happening is out in the open
these days you have people who've called
consent monitors that sometimes run
around these parties.
It's also not uncommon to be standing
there negotiating with someone where your
friend or their friend
is right next to them.
The idea is that that kind of social
monitoring makes things safer. Anyhow,
I asked her to zoom in on a
specific consent conversation.
How does it usually go?
Uh, people with different experiences,
levels are better and worse at this.
Typically like let's say I was
going to play with you, right?
Like you're telling me you've never done
anything like this before, right? Zero,
zero. So, uh, I like to knife top,
which is a way of describing the fact
that I like to do things with knives on
two people. Actual cutting
of people or, or no, no,
this is just dragging knives along
people and sort of threatening with them,
like playing with knives and in truth,
the thing that I do to make it more
interesting as I like to cut people's
clothes off of them big,
I teach a whole class on
how to cut people's clothes
off of them with knives or
they are they like cerated uh, it can be,
so some of them have rough
edges and some of them don't.
And that's actually one of the
questions I would ask you. So, um,
I would ask you if you, you may be,
would be more interested in sort of
a poking type sensation or more of a
scraping tight sensation based on just
hearing that I'm gonna go with dragging.
I would select my knives accordingly at
that point cause I have separate knives
for these purposes. Um, and then I would,
if I was gonna cut your clothes
off, for example, I would ask you,
I would let you know that there's,
I, I'm, I'm pretty good at what I do,
but there's no way that
I can guarantee that, uh,
I won't cut something that you
don't want me to. So if possible,
it'd be great if you could take off the
thing that you wouldn't want me to cut,
right. Like a necklace or
your socks or whatever.
And I also like warn people going into
them like I'm pretty experienced with
this, but I definitely have
accidentally cut people before. So, um,
you know, I just need to let you know
that this is not a 100% guarantee.
If or if that's something that you
absolutely cannot tolerate, then uh,
then we probably can't go forward with
this. Or if you say, well, I mean,
I'm fine with it as long as it isn't on
my arms cause I don't want to show up
for work. That's like great. Like,
well I'll just restrict
what I do to not your arms.
She said sometimes she'll even get a
pen and make a tiny little dot on all of
the places the person says are off limits.
Just so she can be super duper
sure. She's respecting their wishes,
their classes. I, hello everyone. Uh,
most well organized BDSM
scenes in the country.
Okay. You guys are allowed
to talk here. Believe me,
I know we have mikes around.
Have weekly or at least monthly
classes. We actually went to one.
How many people here have taken any
of my events before? Raise of hands.
There we go. Everyone else is new.
It was in Manhattan, a small studio
space. About 15 people were there. And uh,
the instructor,
a guy named dominous arrows was sort of
at the front of the room in a leather
kilt with these two leather
straps across. Yeah.
Now is everyone here familiar with
consent, please? All right, good.
Is there anyone know what a difference
between consent and enthusiastic consent?
One guy in the back raised his hand.
That's sort of a new thing that's
sort of coming up in a lot of clubs.
If there's a moment of hesitation
in that person's brain,
you should automatically be
picking that up and be like,
do you actually want to
do this thing with me?
And generally within the first 10 seconds,
someone can tell if they
want to have sex with you.
You're not going to convince someone
otherwise you're not gonna be like, man,
I'm going to wear them down wearing not
technique. It pisses me off at a party.
Nobody owes you anything.
Everyone on board so far,
a lot of nods. Good. So, and then, uh,
he sort of demonstrated
how all of this works.
Inaction at first look at the table.
He took everyone over to this table,
showed them the toys,
different kinds of whips.
Floggers little stick
with a feather. Yeah.
Let me grab what this going to be.
My little tool to play around with.
Grabbed one of the floggers
and then he and a woman named
Bella who is in black lingerie,
they a walk over to this giant cross
looking thing in the corner of the room.
She then leads against it.
Good.
So I currently have Bella with the arms
spread on the Saint Andrew's cross.
Her legs going to be a little bit wider.
Fella is not that tall now we've
already had our top. Hey, what's cool,
I just met you. Am I allowed to put
my hand in your ass? The shoulders,
your skin.
Do you want to keep you close as is
late or do you want to sort of slowly on
dressed as we play? Get all your things
because you don't know where they're at.
They could tell you just
want to be like this.
Bella has told me she just don't want
to take any more clothes off. Correct.
Bella? Bella also doesn't
like a huge amount of pain,
so then we go with that feeling. All
right. That's like your shoulders,
a little funky. You want to warm them up.
You don't go to the gym and do your
heavier set right away. Correct.
You going to sort of warm up the muscles?
I do light touching. Like hitting.
You start slowly whipping
your shoulders. Yeah.
Some nights you get that. Here.
I'm sort of just observing, waiting for
their body, sort of tell me some notes.
When I do impact, their body's
going to tell me something.
If I go a little heavy.
Okay,
there's a little bit of a turtling
in see you. The hips crawl in.
If the ass comes right back out right
away, that's saying, daddy hit me again.
Right? If this stays turtle,
then I've went a little heart.
I can come in and stay and again,
you're talking can be sexy.
It's not so much for you. Baby
is daddy needs to go lighter,
keep sexy. You don't have to
say, hey, was that too hard?
You can totally keep it in
very sexy and see how it goes.
Staying engaged is very important.
If you're in a space that's loud,
you can't fucking hear anything.
So I can hear if she's moaning
or if she's like, oh, you know,
so I want to be able to get my
ears in clothes, see how they do.
Then I create this sort of cadence,
play around a little bit more and from
there I'm combining between using impact
play and sense play.
We'll go a little more in depth once you
guys start playing around a little bit.
And I'll go around the room
because I want to get into the
workshop aspect where dominance spent
the next hour sort of moving around the
room,
helping people as they paired off with
their whips and their floggers learn how
to better read each other.
And for a moment it felt like,
oh, we should all be doing this.
I mean maybe not using whips and having
sex in public unless that's your thing,
but finding ways to help each other be
explicit and communicative and to have a
code for what words mean.
When we talked to college age men,
women, a lot of them were like,
we need a script. We need
something written down. Because a,
one of the things that's been found
in surveys is that there's very little
agreed upon language. For example, the
phrase like slow down when surveyed,
many college aged women will tell you
that means stop. Many men will say, no,
it just means goes slower.
Well, in the BDSM world,
they seem to have sorted some of this out.
So like I was at a play party
and it said on the thing, oh,
house rules say yellow means, uh, I,
you should check in or
pause. Red Means Stop.
And if somebody says safe
word, that means that, uh,
you're calling for help from
one of the people that's around.
It all seemed so clear and sensible.
And Dare I say uncomplicated, but
Julia was like, ah, yeah, no, no.
Really.
When we come back, Julie Rains on
the parade that we were throwing her.
This is Kelly calling from San Francisco.
Radio lab is supported in part
by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
there are doors that once
opened to never be closed.
W NYC studios and snap judge
with underground layer spooked.
Season two is here. Listen now,
every week until Halloween. Be Afraid,
but don't turn out the lights.
Listen to speak
wherever you get your podcasts.
Hey, I'm Jad, we're back.
Third installment of in the know
and Julie was about to tell us,
Julie [inaudible] that uh, even in the
BDSM world with its very clear, uh,
rules and safe words like red
and yellow things go wrong.
The actual real problem with that yellow,
red situation is that in public
people almost never end up using red.
Like there's one of the huge problems
that the BDSM subculture basically has is
that there's massive,
massive social repercussions to calling
red in a public place basically.
And as we talked about this more a,
it's started to sound a lot like what
we heard from the college aged women,
uh, that saying no even, you know,
when it's buttress by all of these rules
and norms can still be really hard.
There's a cost.
What are the worst situations that I
ever personally found myself in, um,
was I was tied up in suspended and uh,
so all my feet are off the ground
and I'm having a great time.
I had negotiated ahead of time that there
was to be nothing genital happening.
It was very clear about that. And
I was like, nope, this is not,
this is not a thing.
Then she says the person
who she was playing with who
tied her up decided to try
some genital stuff.
And I was really caught in that moment
because we're in a very public place.
Uh, I could yell red,
but in that place yelling red
means the whole scene has to stop.
And I didn't want the scene to stop.
I liked being tied up and I'm also
cognizant of the fact that this guy is my
friend.
I really like him and I don't want
him to get in a ton of trouble.
But if I yelled red really
loudly in this public place,
there's a pretty decent chance he's
going to get banned from the event.
There's pretty decent chance he's going
to get banned from a lot of events.
And even if I kicked him
in the face and he stopped
cause I was gonna say you're
tied up though. That's very,
the whole point is you're
in a compromised situation.
I am in a compromised situation,
but it turns out it puts my
feet a lot closer to his face
even though she a navigated that one
fine in the end she says generally
speaking, the BDSM community is in
terms of the consent negotiation,
not a utopia. In fact,
what she experienced in that moment
was for a long time, not uncommon.
So I should explain that the [inaudible]
actually got its own Mitsu movement
about three months before the me too
movement hit like I didn't have that
Hashtag but exactly the
same thing happened where a
bunch of high status people
got out at his consent violators in the
scene. These are a bunch of dudes are,
yeah, they're all men.
There's definitely a lot of consent
violations that happened with women,
but people don't pay attention to it.
And I have a whole other rant about that,
but people who got a lot of attention on
them were men and pretty much everyone
that they had hurt was women.
And that's part of the reason
that Julie is, uh, in the end,
a little suspicious of all of the
rules that we were just enamored of,
or I should say she's a little suspicious
of placing too much faith in those
rules. It's
not, it's not foolproof, rightly
so. I mean, I know people who
they don't want to tell you anymore
that they're not having fun.
So there's a real sense of like, I don't
want to disappoint this other person.
So one of the things that I also will
ask in these types of negotiating my
version of negotiation is like,
do you feel reasonably certain that you
will be able to tell me if you don't
like what's happening?
The more I thought about that question,
like after we'd done the
interview in morning,
I was sort of noodling on that
I the crew to me like what?
That's a key question. Can
you say no when you need to?
Some of us just are people
pleasers. I am one of those people,
it hurts to say no if you know
it's good bumps someone out,
others have no problem
with that. So she asks,
which kind of person are you
right now? It is situational.
Who are you at this moment?
If they say, yeah, right now,
I'm not good with the no, then she goes
one direction. If they say, no, no,
I could tell you
then I'm like, all right,
can we both agree that we are
adults,
that we don't have to get into all this
stuff about what we don't want to have
happen
and that we will take responsibility
for actually communicating how we're
feeling in a situation. And if
we fail to communicate that,
that we will also take
responsibility for that.
So are you okay with kind of whatever and
you're going to tell me if you're not,
and the other person goes, yes. That's
how I want that to go. At that point,
our conversation changes from what am
I not allowed to do to what do you find
hot?
One of the things that we kept
running into again and again was, um,
this sentiment that, uh, was maybe
best captured by a guy that Becca,
and she misspoke too.
I'm Michael [inaudible].
I'm the director of empowering victims
and I'm one of the people who came up
with the concept for the we consent app.
That app was actually the one,
uh, that a guy last episode, uh,
sort of jokingly referred
to. Hello. Would you be like,
can I record you on my cell phone of
you saying you're down to make out right
now? Turns out it's actually
a real app that this guy made.
There's no really good,
the problem is that we've got to meme in
the meeting is already well established
and the meme is consent.
Unfortunately that mean frames
the entire question the wrong way.
Consent means that you're giving someone
permission to do something to you.
We don't do sex to someone else.
We have sex with someone else.
Are you saying that that's the like
dictionary definition of consent?
It's interesting cause I'm curious
if this is just like a semantic
for this of consent is giving someone
permission to do something to you or on
your behalf.
Yeah, I just looked it up. And you're so
compliance and or approval of what
is done or proposed by another
wrong word.
And, uh, Joe for Shell, the academic
that we heard from earlier. Yeah. If
it doesn't capture what I think
is probably the biggest problem,
young people and for sex on college
campuses, which is all of the sex,
it's consensual but unhappy and
unpleasant and unwanted and people,
typically women endure the core issue
may not be non-consent and it may not be
sex discrimination.
It might be the fact that
men are leveraging their
positions of power to extract
sex from women that don't
want to be there. And I,
and I think it's hard to target that
problem if you call it non-consent.
[inaudible]
it was the second day I went home with
him and I wasn't really sure if I wanted
to sleep with him and I was kind
of going through the motions. Um,
and at one point he pulled away cause
you could tell that I was like not
entirely there. And he's like, do
you want to have sex? Um, and I,
I kind of said like, ah,
like I didn't even say yes or no and he
just stopped entirely. And we just like,
and that was it. And
I remember being like,
like relieved first and
like really surprised, um,
because he read my body like the second
date, like read my body language,
respected me and like didn't push.
I was at a bar a couple
of weeks ago and, um,
I was with this girl and you know,
she was, we were both, you know,
we're both pretty drunk and
she was like, yeah, hey,
you want to go out to my place?
And I was like, I can't do that.
Like I'm drunk. You're drunk.
Like, she's like, you're right.
And just kind of like we've
out, we continue to like
dance. I was fine. It was,
we had a fine night and then like I
woke up the next morning and she, uh,
texted me and was like, Hey,
thank you so much for like
not taking advantage of me.
Like that means a lot. I was
like, that was really easy.
I've been lucky in that regard that like
if I'm uncomfortable having sex with
like my partner, like, like right
when I'm about to be like, I can't,
like I don't want to do this right now.
He always catches like my eye is like,
like he'll stop immediately
in, in like, you know,
I've had like my own sex trauma
stuff and he like, I'm going to cry,
but like he will stop.
It's so nice to have a partner that
can like read your body language and be
like, this doesn't feel like
feel right. Are you okay?
[inaudible]
this episode was reported
by Becca Bressler and Sheba
only alley and produced by
Bethel hop tay.
Very special thanks to Katelyn crest and
the team she worked with at the heart
to produce that series that inspired this
whole thing for us to all the men and
women who shared their stories with us.
Thanks to Metta Prieto Rovell cheques,
Samantha Shahi, Laney goodwill,
Don Black, Margot Weiss,
dominance arrows and pagans
paradise objet album. Rod, thanks.